bonjour quand j'étais petit je répare et
l'aspirateur jeu le démonte est pour
comprendre comment il fonctionnait
trouver la panne et je le répare et
aujourd'hui je suis un médecin passionné
par la machine humaine et ce qui
m'intéresse le plus c'est de comprendre
et traiter les causes des maladies
plutôt que les symptômes
j'ai commencé à l'hôpital en
cancérologie là j'ai vu mourir beaucoup
de mes patients ces échecs répétés m'ont
dit qu'il fallait que je me tourne
plutôt vers la prévention de la santé
et là tout simplement je me suis rendu
compte que tout ce que j'avais appris
sur l'hygiène de vie ne suffisait pas
que le plaisir le stress étaient des
facteurs très importants dans notre
santé et donc c'est tout naturellement
que je me suis tourné ensuite vers la
prévention de la santé mentale et de la
santé mentale particulièrement ou
travail parce que nous passons une
grande partie de notre vie au travail
et là le constat fait froid dans le dos
nous avons aujourd'hui un tiers de la
population des salariés en france qui
sont en stress chronique
cela veut dire qu'ils ne peuvent plus
agir
ils sont dans une incapacité à faire
face et là effectivement dans ce monde
du travail en a deux solutions soit on
va au front et une grande partie des
salariés mettent en danger leur santé 25
% 25 % des salariés aujourd'hui mettre
en danger leur santé sont des épidémies
de burn out
ce sont des maladies cardiovasculaires
précoces des dépressions des tentatives
de suicide et des suicides
alors on me dit que ce sont les dégâts
collatéraux de la mondialisation
mais peut-on continuer à perdre sa vie
ainsi elle a gagné eh bien non et
certains noms déjà bien compris puisque
pour sauver leur peau ils fuient ils
fuient ils se désengagent de
l'entreprise nous avons aujourd'hui 9 %
seulement de salariés très engagé dans
les organisations et nous avons même 26
% des salariés qui sont activement des
engagés alors ces salariés là bas ils
mettent leur intelligence ailleurs en
dehors de l'entreprise
la question qu'on doit se poser c'est
peut-on se priver ainsi de
l'intelligence de l'énergie des talents
de tous ces gens qui sont soit malade
soit en fuite
surtout dans une période de crise on
aurait plutôt besoin de tout le monde
alors je me suis dit mais que s'est il
passé
évidemment on vous voit et tout de suite
trois causes principales 1 3 éléments
forts c'est que premièrement le monde a
changé et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on
est en compétition sur toute la planète
on est dans un monde hyper financiarisé
on est dans un monde aussi on est en
connexion permanente et vous le savez 24
heures sur 24 on doit être joignable
on doit être performant il ya une chose
importante aussi c'est qu'on a
individualiser les résultats il ya de
moins en moins de soutien du collectif
le collectif s'est effondré et justement
même les plus forts s'effondre alors
effectivement face à à tout cela le
travail lui aussi a changé donc le monde
a changé le travail a changé et ça vous
le savez vous le vivez nous vivons tous
le travail s'est intensifiée il s'est
complexifiée tout va plus vite on n'a
plus le temps de s'adapter aux
différentes transformations
on est même obligé de faire parfois un
travail qui n'est pas vraiment de
qualité on en perles estime de soi on
est toujours très seul aussi
dans les organisations aujourd'hui face
aux différents types de changements
cette incapacité à s'adapter nous fait
du mal
troisièmement troisième cause
intéressante c'est que les attentes
aussi des salariés ont énormément changé
vous le savez aujourd'hui tout le monde
a envie d'avoir un travail intéressant
et les jeunes générations en plus envie
d'avoir un vrai bon équilibre entre leur
vie professionnelle et leur vie
personnelle et c'est bien légitime
tout le monde veut être acteur et
aujourd'hui ce qui est compliqué c'est
qu'en fait on a un grand écart un très
grand écart entre à la fois cet
esclavagisme moderne et en même temps
c'est envie de s'épanouir au travail
nous avons créé un nombre de défiance
entre les dirigeants et ceux qui
exécutent où l'on n'est plus ni vraiment
heureux ni vraiment fier de ce que l'on
fait et pourtant ce n'est jamais le
travail qui rend malade
stéphanie vous l'a dit elle aimait son
métier ça n'a pas rendu malade au
contraire elle est heureuse mais ce sont
les conditions dans lesquelles on exerce
son travail qui aujourd'hui peuvent
nuire à la santé
ce sont les conditions de travail
l'organisation du travail et leurs
relations interpersonnelles
alors effectivement mon combat à moi
aujourd'hui il est là c'est de dire et
si on travaillait autrement et si on
changeait les conditions de travail et
si on parlait de qualité de vie au
travail
mais qu'est ce que la qualité de vie au
travail certains pensent que c'est
d'avoir des beaux bureaux d'autres un
travail intéressant
d'autres avoirs des des massages dans
les entreprises
des séances de yoga de méditation une
salle de sport pour allait lâcher la
pression
tout ça est très efficace très bien mais
ça ne traitent que les symptômes
c'est ce que j'appelle moi la qualité de
vie hors travail je côtoie beaucoup de
chefs d'entreprise ils me disent
florence
en période de crise la qualité de vie au
travail franchement c'est la cerise sur
le gâteau moi je me bats pour défendre
les emplois et moi je leur dis non c'est
pas la cerise sur le gâteau c'est la
sarine du gâteau c'est la levure du
gâteau skis c'est que le gâteau existe
et le premier ingrédient premier
ingrédient pardon de cette qualité de
vie au travail
c'est la confiance la confiance est le
terreau effectivement sur lequel à
partir duquel on peut aller prendre des
risques innover sortir des sentiers
battus et quand on innove avec on arrive
avec des produits nouveaux et bien on
est de nouveau compétitif donc la
qualité de vie au travail
sarr et engage les gens ça met de la
confiance et ça apporte de la
performance on le sait bien aujourd'hui
les entreprises sont allés au bout de ce
qu'elle pouvait en termes de
productivité
on a effectivement fait des réductions
de coûts organiser le travail de façon
le plus libre possible
on a mis beaucoup de process en place
beaucoup d'indicateurs mais ce qu'on ait
oublié c'est que seul l'homme créer de
la valeur
on a oublié en chemin le facteur humain
alors comment faire comment faire pour
remettre l'humain
justement au coeur de l'entreprise on
entend beaucoup ça aujourd'hui et bien
effectivement quand on regarde au 20e
siècle
au siècle dernier c'était pas si loin
que ça nous avons considérablement
allégé pour pas dire supprimer les
souffrances physiques au travail
aujourd'hui au 21ème siècle nous devons
inventer les outils de la prévention de
la santé mentale nous savons
que la prévention est un facteur de
performance économique
quand on est en place de la prévention
sur la santé physique on a un retour sur
investissement de 2 à 4 euros pour un
euro investi
alors aujourd'hui on doit investir dans
la prévention de la santé mentale mais
ça fait peur ça fait peur alors qu'en
réalité ça des justes qu'investir dans
le facteur humain et là regardez bien
une étude toute récente qui date de
septembre 2014 7 au niveau européen nous
a démontré qu investir dans la
prévention la santé mentale rapportait
pour un euro investi 13 euros on se
demande pourquoi on n'y va pas plus vite
pour faciliter sa avec toute mon équipe
nous avons inventé à partir d'un d'une
base de données de près de 30000
salariés un référentiel scientifique
pour définir la qualité de vie au
travail et au final la qualité la
qualité de vie au travail c'est tout
simplement être bien au travail mais
être bien effectivement dans plusieurs
dimensions cinq dimensions vous allez
voir c'est d'abord être bien dans son
job dans ses compétences dans son
employabilité et se sentir en sécurité
c'est être bien aussi au niveau de sa
santé physique mentale mais avoir aussi
de l'autonomie c'est être bien dans son
organisation de travail avec son
management
et c'est là que se discute la charge de
travail la clarté des rôles et des
missions mais aussi la négociation sur
les transformations
c'est aussi être bien avec ses relations
ses relations de travail c'est à dire
être respectée être reconnu être écoutés
être soutenu c'est là aussi que la
sérénité est importante et qu'on a
besoin justement d'un bon équilibre
entre sa vie personnelle et sa vie
professionnelle et enfin
sans aucun doute le plus important c'est
le sens c'est savoir pourquoi je me lève
le matin savoir en quoi mon travail est
utile
est-ce que je partage les valeurs
justement de mon entreprise est ce que
je sais exactement si mon envie est de
faire un travail de qualité et si je me
retrouve aujourd'hui à devoir sert que
de la quantité comment puis-je arrivée
être en cohérence avec moi même chose
essentielle dans le sens aussi c'est
l'exemplarité de la direction c'est elle
qui crée la confiance partager le
pouvoir avoir un sentiment aussi des
kits et ça c'est ce qui crée l'esprit
d'équipé c'est ce qui fait qu'on y va
tous ensemble
alors oui voilà créer des organisations
plus sûr plus saine plus simple plus
sereine et avec plus de sens c'est ça la
qualité de vie au travail et aujourd'hui
ça n'est pas un luxe c'est une nécessité
c'est même la seule option possible
nous l'avons appelé un peu par
provocation la haute qualité humaine
l'ahq h parce que nous entendons
beaucoup d'entreprises très fier d'être
dans des bâtiments hqe haute qualité
environnementale
vous connaissez peut-être dans
lesquelles parfois maltraitent leurs
salariés mais voilà on s'est dit nous
voulons créer la haute qualité humaine
alors créé c'est bien prétentieux je le
reconnais en fait notre idée c'est
simplement de dire que nous voulons
révéler la haute qualité humaine qui
sommeille aujourd'hui dans beaucoup
d'organisation deuxièmement nous
voudrions que ce hq h sont un déclic une
sorte de déclic pour réfléchir et se
dira peut-être ya des façons différentes
de faire les choses et aujourd'hui ce
qui compte beaucoup c'est la façon dont
on fait les choses plus parfois même que
ce que l'on fait et enfin le troisième
élément fort de ce hq h ce serait de
pouvoir le transforment et demain en
label pour un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui font justement en
bonne santé
c'est important de se dire aujourd'hui
que les choses peuvent changer
mais surtout ce que j'ai compris en
travaillant sur tous ces éléments c'est
que peut-être la cause principale de
tous ces soucis c'est que l'on ne se
parlent plus que l'on ne s'écoutent plus
c'est le manque de dialogue qui est à
l'origine de toutes ces problématiques
d'organisation du travail de mauvaises
relations au travail et que donc nous
sommes nous sommes des animaux sociaux
nous avons besoin nous parler nous avons
besoin d'échanger et nous avons besoin
d'intelligence collective aujourd'hui
plus encore qu'hier pour résoudre les
problèmes complexes auxquelles nous
sommes soumis
alors oui j'ai commencé par soigner des
individus aujourd'hui je soigne des
organisations de façon pragmatique je
vous dirais bien qu'il n'y a pas de
solution miracle il n'y a pas de
baguette magique c'est comme contre le
cancer
y'a aucun médicament efficace en
revanche si on met en place
effectivement des solutions une
association de thérapeutique
à ce moment là on est très efficace et
si on agit sur les cinq axes où il est
très efficace alors beaucoup de gens me
disent laurencie très compliqué on n'a
pas le choix si on veut travailler
il faudrait changer les mentalités
il faudrait diminuer le pouvoir des
actionnaires ils me disent que je suis
très utopiste de vouloir changer le
monde du travail
je leur dit non parce que ce qu'il faut
faire savoir aujourd'hui c'est que
simplement les employés heureux sont
aussi trois fois et demie plus
performant
il faut juste que chacun s'y mette nous
pouvons tous devenir de meilleurs êtres
humains
ensemble nous pouvons le faire nous
devons tous savoir l'utopie de rendre le
monde meilleur et victor hugo disait il
existe une chose plus puissante que
toutes les armées du monde
c'est une idée dont l'heure est venue je
suis convaincu que l'heure de la haute
qualité humaine est venu je vous
remercie